now on the derpy squares what is this
son oh wow yeah Bravo
all right son you had it out some fun
Braun level oh it's just like the
magical fanciful world that I was
experiencing before gotta watch out for
that oh it's so joking and wonderful all
right mr. troll course ah you won't
actuate if I don't touch you eh
ha ha ha we have fun son don't we yeah I
know we do oh don't want to go too fast
over here yes oh oh gotta crawl to my
dumb ah stop trying to suck your own
dick and get out of here ah what is that
oh that's not something it was coming
uh-huh we're okay kid I seem to be
pretty much standard fare for me I ain't
got a problem I'm too pro for the likes
of you oh there we go
ha ha ha that didn't hurt at all got it
nailed it ha I kind of grabbed without
an arm ok still ok so ok
ha you almost got me there dem row
you're my son my son okay dodge you I
want to kill you son because you are
awesome did you cheat up pro skills done
let me just stand here like a ballerina
with this shard of glass up my ass again
as we still alive right up the crotch
alright
screw the Pogo guy who needs them balls
in here have enough time for the limp
sweater turned out of my way
uh-uh I gotta deliver the presents to
the crash doctor me buy whiskey dad
daddy needs us eggnog ah crap move to
fat oh come on eat cookies no I should
have worked off those calories
jazzercising ah
okay kill them kill them
ha ha ha kill myself what do you think
ha rainbow ball throw deluxe ah oh that
was +1 no Toy Story okay
there once was a little man named woody
honey did all that he could he he went
to bed where he laid down his head ah
someone didn't like my poetry kill them
rainbow ball throw don't [ __ ] with me
kill me door Kearney's star boy who the
hell is star boy gah my wife
oh hi Joker hey buddy what you doing
there a mind getting off my car yeah
kill them all
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like what
your son you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel want to help the
channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video